Even though both of Marvel’s world-famous
super-teams debuted in the exact same month
of the exact same year, the X-Men and the
Avengers have had their own unique problems
to worry about in the 50 years since.
So as much as fans might hate today’s blockbuster
reality of separate studios keeping universes
from crossing over, it isn’t too different
from the comics.
That being said, the Mutant do-gooders and
Earth’s Mightiest Heroes have found a few
reasons to cross paths (or swap members) over
the years.
And when the X-Men and Avengers meet, there’
just one question on fans’ minds: when you
get right down to it, who’s the stronger
team?
It’s not an easy question to answer – or
even one Marvel wants people to ask – but
it’s a fun one to explore.
In the comics or on the big screen, any competition
has to begin with the most obvious question:
who would win in a fight?
We’ll try to answer this question and more
in our latest Docu Series: X-Men vs The Avengers:
Who is Marvel’s Most Powerful Team?
The Leaders
While most comic book fans would tell you
that Captain America has emerged as the de
facto leader of the Avengers, the team’s
origins, and the version seen in Marvel’s
Cinematic Universe have viewed Steve Rogers
as the heart, but not necessarily the brains
(or the money) behind the team.
That duty fell to billionaire superhero Tony
Stark, always one step ahead of the problem,
with enough technology and wit to solve it.
For the X-Men, it’s an easier question:
Scott Summers a.k.a. Cyclops is the embodiment
of a fearless leader, and while he may be
lacking in funds or gadgets compared to the
Avengers’ resident beam-weapon-blaster,
he makes up for it in courage and determination.
If we’re talking purely about power, Cyclops
has an edge: Tony Stark’s famous armor and
on-board attacks are powerful, but they can’t
hold a flame to Cyclops’ eye blasts, channeling
massive beams of concussive force from an
alternate dimension.
Unfortunately, the students and teachers at
the Xavier School don’t really believe in
armor.
Combine that with Iron Man’s ability to
fly, and it’s hard to believe Tony wouldn’t
come out on top – even if he lacks the conviction
or inspiration Cyclops has in spades.
Edge: Avengers
The Lost Warriors
Two men blessed with increased durability,
agility, reflexes and strength: one, a clawed
mutant who’s impossible to kill, and the
other, a soldier out of time who will never
give up.
The comparisons between Captain America and
Wolverine might not be obvious on the surface,
but they’ve got more in common than you
think.
Burying a past filled with dead friends and
loved ones, and with only the war to give
them purpose, you have to think that any fight
between the two would end in cold beers, instead
of blood.
But our mission demands that we not just imagine
the amazing flurry of feet, fists, and sprayed
sparks that this fight would entail, but who
would emerge victorious.
Even in the most even fights, you have to
put your money on the one who heals instantly.
But the fact that most comic book fans wouldn’t
WANT to see these two heroes fight to the
death perfectly demonstrates how even the
teams really are.
Edge: X-Men
The Witches
Now we’re talking about true power: in the
Avengers corner, there’s Scarlet Witch,
a troubled woman struggling to control the
magical powers she is able to wield over reality
itself.
In the X-Men corner, there’s Jean Grey,
a troubled woman struggling to control the
mutant and cosmic powers she is able to wield
over reality itself.
We would usually call this one a draw – since
Scarlet Witch is also a player in Marvel’s
version of the “Ultimate” Avengers – but
add in the Phoenix Force that makes Jean Grey
the most powerful mutant in the universe,
and nobody, not even her teammates can hope
to survive.
Edge: X-Men
The Gods
What’s a fight without some thunder and
lightning.
It’s actually weird how perfectly these
teams stack up against eachother… almost
as if they were created by the exact same
men at the exact same time….
Anyway, the god of thunder taking on a goddess
of nature, if you believe the legacy of Storm’s
family, is the kind of fight that comics exist
to make possible.
Both are serious aces in the hole for both
teams, since controlling the wind, clouds,
and lightning isn’t a tool most villains
can call on.
But again, one little factor seems to make
all the difference: one of these two is as
hard to kill as a Norse god, and the other…
isn’t.
Edge: Avengers
The Hulk Vs…
This one is pretty self-explanatory: the Avengers
have a Hulk.
The X-Men have plenty of angry mutants, brilliant
mutants, and even some green ones… but zero
Hulks.
Edge: Avengers
The Running Totals
Putting the heroes head-to-head shows that
they really are a solid match – which is
probably why their track record of ACTUAL
fights in the comics usually end in a draw
(and more often than not, somebody is being
misled, manipulated, or mind-controlled).
When the teams first met in combat while they
both tried to capture the villain Lucifer
in 1965, it was Professor X who stopped the
fight before one team came out on top (http://readcomiconline.me/Comic/Uncanny-X-Men-1963/Issue-9?id=23308).
The champion was actually chosen when the
X-Men were mind-controlled into fighting the
Avengers, and were taken down one by one:
Beast fell to Black Panther, Ant-Man went
giant to defeat Cyclops, Hawkeye outsmarted
Ice-Man, and so on, and so on (http://readcomiconline.me/Comic/The-Avengers-1963/Issue-53?id=11431).
But two decades later the score was settled
when the mutants won a moral and legal victory
in the X-Men vs Avengers series (http://spinoff.comicbookresources.com/wp-content/uploads/2014/05/AVX-003.jpg).
The epic showdown between both sides in 2012’s
“Avengers VS X-Men” turned out to be a
draw as well, with both teams working together
to take out the Phoenix Force.
Which might be the entire point: the teams
are both as powerful as Marvel can make them.
Who wins in a fight?
That question can’t be answered, since the
people writing the comics know that it’s
a conflict which shouldn’t and couldn’t
be that simple.
So, the teams are different, but equal, then.
While the Avengers tackle alien villains and
protect the Earth from supervillains the world
over, the X-Men tackle mutant villains and
crises, working to keep mutants capable of
re-writing history and time itself in control.
To be honest, the fact that both teams have
failed in their missions in some pretty high-profile
storylines would suggest that they BOTH have
some room to grow before claiming they’re
“the most powerful,” but in Hollywood,
there’s at least one clear winner.
The Box Office Champion
The X-Men movie universe and its solo Wolverine
adventures has done well for itself on film,
bringing in more than 3 billion dollars in
total.
But compare that to Marvel, having now brought
in over 10 billion worldwide, and the Star-Spangled
hero’s crew of misfits has claim to the
crown.
So, is it enough to be the most powerful Marvel
super-team when it comes to ticket sales?
Even if it is, we’ve got some bad news:
although Fox’s X-Men universe has less than
half the box office totals of Marvel’s Avengers,
they made it with half as many movies.
Which is either a massive coincidence, or
proof that the universe itself wants Marvel
fans divided on which team reigns supreme.
Conclusion
So what do you think?
Is it only right that Marvel’s two greatest
teams should come to a tie whenever they compete?
Or do you think the rise of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe beats Hugh Jackman’s Wolverine
and friends hands down?
The future of the movies may not offer an
answer, but in today’s world of billion-dollar
superhero blockbusters, almost anything is
possible.
Let us know your thoughts in the comments,
and remember to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one.